honest trailers time for baby drive of
people you excited I'm excited Edgar
Wright's excited Simon Pegg and Nick
Frost are excited we're all excited and
before we do that I wanted to give a
patron of the day shout out for Scuba
Steve Scuba Steve school Bastille all
the way in Rhode Island Island this guy
currently works at a bagel shop but I
likes his horn movies and his
independent films and he's also a
graffiti artist you can check him out on
Instagram as Scuba Steve underscore 401
this guy is a very nice gentleman I
think he's a sexy gentleman Steve is my
father's name so I am naturally
attracted to you yes you know how that
goes every man falls in love with his
father yeah so I love you and I follow
you on Instagram so you guys should
follow him too I like it so I've got
Steve's work just on public property
we're gonna see Kevin Spacey in this
probably they're probably gonna comment
on how awkward that is now one two three
[Music]
you've been obsessed with everything
Edgar Wright has ever made he hasn't
we're now prepared to be obsessed with a
movie he's been obsessed with for the
last 22 years 22 dang if he made it back
then honza would have been an actual
baby
baby driving future baby 2017 cheapest
Halloween costume whether he's using his
criminal why don't any of these
criminals work with this snitch let's
say you know someone doesn't have a real
job get ready for awesome stunt driving
like you wouldn't because baby's got
more skills behind the wheel then that
other mostly so dropping get away under
one bullet one part iPod commercial and
three parts
okay go video automotive thrills
strapped in for tightly choreographed
gunplay
money Stuckey buddies tacky yeah oh yeah
okay white boy dance there I can do that
[Music]
put it out baby look at my nerves just
give him the sandwich baby strap it in
for babies last job for the creepy
bank-robbing ringleader dog who's even
more creepy because he's played by a
priest candle Kevin Spacey
who's even more creepy because he says
stuff like this to a young man you and
my lucky charms around with Christopher
Plummer spaced on him creepy experience
a love story between a boy and the girl
who's clearly a standard for the boys
dad mom yeah see you fall in love with
your parent she was a singer too I guess
but you mainstream for Tarantino plus a
recording studio so adorkable
it could take Zooey Deschanel mellow in
an overall musical experience that will
have you revving your minivan on the way
to soccer practice
Kluber again the Furious enjoy Edgar
Wright school love my car quick that was
his highest performer at the box office
today
whoa though he doesn't even drive a
single baby
maybe there's a film the delivers on the
title skids and Draper sir
[Music]
[Laughter]
right city your real name Wow
great because I needed more help getting
miles Taylor Ottawa Al Gore and the
ready player one got confused
I'm just glad that cows can't fly people
are stupid but at least we have cotton
candy I was really happy with how they
handled that Kevin Spacey bit yeah
because it was very obvious that the
Christopher Plummer thing was coming the
way they drove that half of that joke
yeah the way they can't because I felt
like the one time they did it like that
they can't do it like you've missed from
the rest of the trip all the names of
the titles cuz it gets like towed right
out of that movie yeah really
hammering a lot of these baby jokes huh
yeah well it didn't seem like they hat
like too many criticisms to go had to
jump on some there was no baby
references just keep hammering in
history I mean they pointed out a couple
of things you know he is constantly like
recording criminal activity and things
like that for his own leisure
he doesn't wear gloves to cover up his
fingerprints yeah yeah yeah which I
don't know I never been printed before I
guess that's not a it's not a big deal
but you should be probably a little
extra sewer probably probably wear some
different clothes I like the whole remix
thing I didn't realize Lily James looks
so much like Skye forever
so they put yeah I totally forgot
that together was she I just thought I
just thought it was another casting of
another bunch of white people in a movie
yeah it was a crop of attractive young
when they pointed that out there I'm
like oh that might have been some like
little detail that a girl did throw in
here and I mean he's so intentional with
most like it seems like most things in
his movies are very composed so I
wouldn't be surprised if there was no
intentional every man falls in love with
his father that's right just like we
said at the top of the video so it was
an infant driver oh we have another baby
Joe baby baby
[Music]
Zana sugar it really doesn't spoil a
whole lot no so I'm wondering how very
few plot points is trailer I wonder have
someone actually just have didn't see
baby driver but then saw the honors
trailer how they would feel about the
movies gives away weird details
yeah and like weird motifs that keep
popping with if you're someone think
this is actually a good movie for I
don't know yeah it's actually a pretty
good question it's weird when they can't
when they don't riff as hard when
they're just kind of pointing out
esoterica about a certain film yeah I
wonder if it would make it it probably
would make it look kind of strange and
at the very least and I'm so glad they
pointed out how it does have
similarities to drive and in certain
aspects I felt like no one was pointing
that out
I totally different movie but you know
stylist jacket quiet driver likes his
music yes I'm a getaway driver it
definitely has that motive and even even
drive is borrowing from stuff you know
in Drive is only 100 percent
it's 100 percent may not taking or
derive anything invented getaway drivers
in pop music
whining wrapped up in a cold sweat one
night and wind I know what it is the
person who drives the getaway car will
focus on that guy and then everyone was
like what are you talking about it's
never gonna work man whether you're
gonna lose this a bunch of money this
joke is great don't you want to yes and
me right now you're preggers aiyah I
mean this would make sense of this this
is highest-grossing movie it's funny to
me cuz this strikes me as his most sort
of markedly original film you know cuz
you got the car
a trilogy which is not you know based on
properties so to speak but it's you know
building on a concept and then you have
so because I got specific genres yeah
yeah yeah and it's got its own little
world to adhere to and then you have
Scott Pilgrim which is obviously based
on the comics and so like to have
something like this it's just his omage
to get away movies and stuff be the one
that is the most successful it's kind of
cool your original piece and the piece
that has like all your passion for music
in it and this one the Blues passion
project for 22 years
where was originally a baby yeah hey man
if you hadn't waited so long he could
have really made it accurate but hey
young man driver is just as kids to give
friendly comedy at the time hey no one
would suspect it's a baby just turns out
this child is a driving survivor strain
jockeys thanks for putting this together
and baby driver was a delightful film
and you can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell so
subscribe bye didn't mean something you
can check us out patron for line TV show
reactions weekly Q it is love to have
you
you